hallo herzlich willkommen in meiner
kochwelt heute mache ich einen leckeren
salat es gibt eine papaya salat papaya
ist ja so eine frucht in exotische
frucht ist nicht gesund und deswegen
habe ich mir gedacht kommen aber noch
mal an frischen salat mit der anne von
betis hatte ich einmal zusammen ein
video gedreht und sie hatte auch einen
leckeren salat gemacht und es war so ein
gurke papaya salat und ich habe heute
auch gurke mit dabei aber auch noch was
nicht wasser sondern eine melone mit
dabei und es wird ziemlich lecker also
ich sag ich einmal kurz die zutaten
ich habe hier eine große papa oder ihr
leben zwei kleine hier habe ich eine
melone zwei avocados so eine handvoll
erdnüsse zwei limetten und eine zitrone
eine gurke also so eine große salatgurke
hier habe ich einen teelöffel zucker
etwas olivenöl salz und pfeffer und ich
mache das ganze jetzt so dass ich das
ganze obst und gemüse einfach fein
würfeln
ich mache das jetzt mit der
küchenmaschine mit der kitchenaid und
nehmen da diesen würfel auf ihr könnt
aber zum beispiel auch wenn ihr habt den
alligator von mir nehmen oder das ganze
einfach mit messer kleinschneider geht
alles gut hauptsache man hat am ende
kleine würfel so so erstmals die papaya
habe ich auch noch nie gezeigt in dem
museum also ich selber habe es im video
noch nie benutzt
die wird jetzt einmal geschält und wenn
sie unreif ist also da nicht dennoch
ziemlich hart und auch nicht so dunkel
und dann hat sie noch also da ich
ständig so süß und da können dass er
dann sollten auch benutzen für herzhafte
gerichte und wenn sie dann eben reifer
und weicher erstanden ist ziemlich süß
man könnte also auch für desserts zum
beispiel benutzen die karts übrigens
auch zu den melonen gewächsen als ich im
prinzip auch nur melone nur eben hat von
uns hier sondern aus dem ausland
dann schneide ich jetzt da hinten dieses
ende noch weg und vorne und halb ihr es
jetzt einfach mal die spitzel geschichte
mit ein bisschen aufpassen
und dann sind da drinnen so ganz viele
schwarze kerne die kann man auch essen
ich muss sagen ich habe sie noch nie
probiert ich probiere jetzt mal ein
es muss nicht unbedingt sein da sind
anscheinend so weichmacher drin die zum
feld fleisch weich machen also da kann
man das ganz gut benutzen aber wie
gesagt ich nehme jetzt raus
ich glaube da wo die papas wachsen da
benutzen die auch die papierblätter
entwickeln dass da irgendwie fleisch ein
und dann soll das fleisch ganz zart
werden habe ich gestern noch gelesen
wir haben hier nur die papier
und jetzt verteidigt sie nochmal in so
viertel ich denke dadurch dass da oben
rein passen dies ziemlich weich ich
probiere es jetzt einfach ob es geht
aber normalerweise müsste es gut
funktionieren
das ist halt echt gut geeignet für
weiches und hagel
dann nehme ich mir die melone das ist
übrigens eine katalog per mail ohne
schablone noch nie so gespielt aber sie
kommen ursprünglich aus dem iran also da
wurden die ursprünglich angebaut und
mittlerweile gibt es die aber in spanien
und frankreich und so weiter und die ist
auch schön süß ich mag die oft ganz
gerne die hat er so eine orange und
oranges fruchtfleisch sieht man kann es
auch ein sparschäler schälen spricht
sogar besser weil dann schneidet man
jetzt auf die fruchtfleisch der
wassermelone über die savanne machen
wird dass jemand auf die idee kommt
die melone halbjährig dann auch und
nehmen auch jede kern heraus die würde
jetzt auch nur bedingt essen wo es
und die wird dann auch schön fein
gewürfelt
die kugel habe ich es auch schon
gestellt und lassen dürfen
das einzige was ich jetzt per hand
würfel ich die avocado den avocados sind
sehr sehr weit
und das müsste ganz einfach mit messer
machen da am besten die avocado einmal
halbieren
da steckt ein großer kern mit drin
den nämlich raus und schneit es fleisch
ist so würfel für mich ein
dann stelle ich das einmal und dann mit
ihrer karte aus der hand und die würfel
auf aus der schale und wenn nicht können
wir gerade diese nachhelfen dem messer
ihr könnt übrigens auch messer einfach
drauf packen und dann den kern heraus
dreht hoch sala börse hand gerutscht
die abokarte bist halt festhalte habe ja
gerade gekriegt
jetzt habe ich das ganze obst und gemüse
zerkleinert und jetzt kommen die
zitrusfrüchte dran
da nehme ich die filets mit rein das
heißt ich nehme oben und unten einfach
den deckel weg jetzt ein bissel nicht
einfach so gut wenn man die aufschneidet
dann hielt die schale entfernen
und dann können wir ganz einfach mit
messer die filets rausschneiden und zwar
sieht man hier diese wende die die
einzelnen filets trennen da einmal links
und einmal rechts und das filet so raus
treten dann die nächste hier an der wand
entlang und so schneidig jetzt beide
institute bei der zitrone und beiden
limetten die filets aus
den rest stellen mittels aphthen könnt
ihr dann einfach mit rein pressen
und jetzt fehlt noch die geheime zutat
für den salat und dafür stehe ich jetzt
auf der terrasse denn wir haben uns hier
so ein kräuterbeet angelegt guckt mal
wie schön dass gewachsen ist sie ist
nicht toll aus und darf lück ich mir
jetzt ein bisschen pfefferminze also das
heißt ein bissl komisch ich guck mir
jetzt hier ganz viele blätter ab ich war
so eine handvoll das dürfte reichen und
später hole ich mir noch welche und
macht mir in frische pfefferminztee sohn
marokkanischer das ist lecker
und jetzt nämlich die frische minze und
zog sie so ein bisschen klein also die
darf gern bisserl grob bleibt aber
einfach dass das ab wo man sich schön
verteilen kann
das ist wirklich so die geheime zutat
also die müsste auf jeden fall mit rein
nehmen weil es den salat noch mal viel
frischer nachtzug in verbindung mit der
limette mit der zitrone also das konto
richtig gut
ich glaub ich hab mal den rabatt bekomme
die ätherische öle aus
erst schlagen dann zupfen
das war gar nicht in der bade beim
afrika dorf auf dem maimarkt es wieder 1
was sage ich da ein bisschen viel salat
ich bin froh dass ich so große schüssel
habe jetzt gebe ich da noch ein bisschen
zucker mit rein zucker und limited es
hebt auch diese den papa geschmack dann
nehme mal zwei drei esslöffel olivenöl
und ich würde das jetzt erst mal durch
damit sieht die schönen vorhaben alle
vermischen und die aromen verbinden
schon echten richtiger sommersalat
dann etwas pfeffer und ich mache das
jetzt so ich las den salat jetzt noch
mal kurz durch 10
denn dann gibt's später zum grillen
deswegen soll sich jetzt nicht alles
sondern nehmen wir jetzt einen teil raus
und zeigt dass importiertes ausgleich
und dann macht es am besten so ihr könnt
ihn wirklich im kühlschrank durchziehen
lassen aber ohne stars also fans bitte
erst zum schluss ansonsten besser da
nämlich so arg vermisst
nehme ich mir hier einen teil raus zum
gleich probieren
aber ich würde auf jeden fall
durchziehen lassen weil dann hat auch
die minze komplett so das aroma
abgegeben und hat sich schön verbunden
alles und ihr könnt auch so machen dass
sie wirklich den salat und gesalzen last
und jeder macht sich dann ebenso viel
salz drauf gehen möchte man hab da
einfach nicht die gefahr dass das ganze
eben bessert verhältnisse darauf die
sind auch gesalzen probieren
ich würde jetzt noch ein bisserl
zitronensaft extra mit rein geben oder
limettensaft wobei ich glaube wenn wir
jetzt noch wissen steht dass er dann die
limette sich auch so ein bisserl drin
auflöst und dann noch mehr es euro
abgibt aber auf jeden fall ist echt ein
toller sommersalat den ihr auf jeden
fall mal nachmachen solltet auch einfach
mal so mittags oder so zu als beilage
und ja die genauen mengenangaben
schreibe ich euch dann auf meinem blog
auf sell list blog.de und ich wünsche
euch ganz viel spaß beim nachmachen und
wir sehen uns dann ganz einfach beim
nächsten mal wieder biss dann süß
ramallah
komm mama